[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 21 décembre voici le
programme de ce 7 8 nous commencerons
cette émission avec les informations du
jour nous parlerons de la venue du
basketteur Florent Pietrus a Rambouillet
nous ferons également un point sur la
cyberattaque survenue le 3 décembre
dernier à l'hôpital Mignot du Chesnay à
Rocancourt Noël c'est donc quatre jours
si vous n'avez toujours pas acheté votre
sapin TB 78 vous propose des astuces
pour bien le choisir pour bien le
conserver nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un vendeur de sapins plus
d'informations dans quelques instants
enfin nous partirons du côté de
Versailles Nathalie bourgeois Deric
magistrate de la cour d'appel est une
grande passionnée de street art son
portrait est à voir dans quelques
instants dans cette émission
le point maintenant sur l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines avec Céline
Charles
[Musique]
la légende du basket français Florent
Pietrus est venu saluer les performances
du club Rambouillet sport Basket le club
a organisé son premier concours All-Star
Game au gymnase Jean-Claude Foulon un
événement auquel le sportif s'est rendu
pour soutenir les joueurs et signer
quelques autographes un plaisir les
trois écoles du valibout vont se
regrouper en un seul groupe scolaire
l'école maternelle Louise-Michel sera
démoli et fusionnera avec l'école
maternelle Daniel Casanova l'école sera
réhabilitée et agrandi passant de 5 à 8
classes et connaîtra de nombreux
aménagements extérieurs l'école
élémentaire Pierre Brossolette connaîtra
aussi quelques changements comme la
création d'une infirmerie ou d'un local
de stockage le pôle éducatif devrait
être livré en juillet 2025 le 3 décembre
dernier l'hôpital André Mignot de
Versailles a été paralysé par une
cyberattaque un événement qui avait
complètement désorganisé l'établissement
17 jours après l'heure est à la
reconstruction l'hôpital tourne
actuellement à 60% de sa capacité les
urgences notamment accueillent sans
passage contre 170 ans normal
l'établissement pourrait prendre
plusieurs semaines avant de trouver un
fonctionnement normal l'enquête est
toujours en cours concernant les auteurs
de l'attaque le maire de Buchelay Paul
Martinez à démissionné de ses fonctions
après 15 ans à la tête de la commune il
souhaite se consacrer pleinement à son
poste de Directeur Général des Services
d'une agglomération de Seine-Maritime il
a cédé son fauteuil à son premier
adjoint Stéphane Tremblay en attendant
de nouvelles élections en février
prochain le professeur Olivier
Saint-Lary médecin généraliste installé
dans les Yvelines et enseignant en
médecine générale à l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a
été réélu à la présidence du collège
national des généralistes enseignants il
est à sa tête depuis 2020 enfin c'est
les derniers jours pour s'inscrire au
festival du court-métrage des clés du
cinéma il ne reste que jusqu'au 31
décembre pour les réalisateurs débutants
ou expérimentés qui souhaiteraient
envoyer leur film l'édition se tiendra
le 12 mars prochain à l'espace Philippe
Noiret pour postuler envoyer votre film
à l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
si vous aussi vous voyez une information
ou une image qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous dans les Yvelines n'hésitez
pas à nous le partager sur Twitter avec
le hashtag 7 8 news le hashtag de tv78
il est la star des fêtes de fin d'année
le sapin de Noël est un incontournable
du mois de décembre mais comment bien le
choisir et le conserver Gabriel Gonthier
Céline charge sont allés poser la
question à Sébastien
[Musique]
à quelques jours de Noël vous faites
peut-être partie de ceux qui n'ont pas
encore choisi leur sapin parmi toutes
les variétés qu'il existe il est parfois
difficile de s'y retrouver nous sommes
donc rendus dans la jardinerie poulain à
La Queue-les-Yvelines rencontré
Sébastien Cayer qui va nous donner ses
conseils pour choisir le plus beau sapin
pour le réveillon
de toutes les couleurs ou plus
naturelles chaque année les sapins
s'arrachent en 2021 c'est 6 millions de
conifères qui ont été vendus en France
bonjour Sébastien bonjour Alors vous
travaillez ici depuis plusieurs années
aujourd'hui vous êtes responsable de
vente comment on choisit son sapin pour
Noël le sapin d'abord avant tout faut
que ça vienne un choix du cœur on arrive
quand même vers Noël et là
malheureusement j'ai plus beaucoup de
sapin qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
mais après ça dépendra de la variété et
de ce que vous voulez en faire le sapin
de Noël idéal c'est quoi c'est un sapin
qui sent bon qui perd pas ses épines ça
dépend de finalement des goûts de chacun
ceux qui préfèrent eux un sapin odorant
plus partir sur de l'épicéa qui
malheureusement perd ses aiguilles et
donc du coup on va venir le chercher
plus tardivement et ceux qui aiment un
sapin qui est beau tout le temps ils
vont préférer sapin qui va garder ses
aiguilles et lui ils vont venir le
chercher dès le début décembre sans
aucun souci et du coup pour nos
spectateurs qui comme nous choisissent
leur sapin un peu de tardivement comment
on conserve bien ce sapin de Noël quand
on le prend dès le début décembre
l'idéal reste de le mettre dans un dans
une soucoupe nous on vous vend des
soucoupes qui vous permettent de mettre
un petit peu d'eau et comme de la fleur
coupée au final comme une rose en vase
évidemment après il y a des petits
détails on évite de le mettre à côté de
la cheminée même si c'est très joli et
très tentant ou à côté d'un radiateur
parce que forcément il va sécher
beaucoup plus vite et la durée de vie
moyenne d'un sapin c'est combien de
temps sur un Norman vous pouvez le
garder sans problème normalement jusqu'à
la galette des rois un épicéa par contre
lui bah il va perdre beaucoup plus vite
ses aiguilles et donc forcément vous le
garderez beaucoup moins longtemps merci
Sébastien kheyer pour tous ces conseils
maintenant vous allez pouvoir choisir
vos sapins et les conserver au mieux
durant toutes les fêtes agis - 4 avant
Noël certains courageux ont affronté la
pluie l'occasion pour nous de leur
demander à quoi ressemble le sapin
parfait je ne sais pas non la forme ma
tête là effectivement quand ils achète
comme ça on peut pas avoir la forme qui
leur a par la suite ça c'est vrai on en
mettant tous les sapins sont beaux tous
les arbres sont beaux c'est à nous de
les embellir alors épicéa ou Norman il
ne vous reste plus qu'à choisir la star
qui sortira le soir de Noël
depuis le mois de septembre 2022
Nathalie Bourgeois a deux Rick occupe la
fonction de première présidente de
chambre à la cour d'appel de Versailles
auprès du premier président
Jean-François beneL une nouvelle étape
dans sa carrière de plus de 30 ans dans
la magistrature en parallèle de sa
profession elle nourrit une passion pour
une activité inscrite pleinement dans la
culture urbaine son portrait par Nicolas
dandry alors moi j'aime bien en général
les fresques donc j'aime bien cet aspect
monumental j'ai réussi à lire art as dit
mais je ne connais pas du tout cet
artiste
la quête aux nouvelles œuvres de street
art dans le 20e arrondissement de Paris
une habitude pour Nathalie bourgeois de
Rick première présidente de chambre à la
cour d'appel de Versailles la magistrate
cultive une passion pour le street art
depuis une dizaine d'années j'aime
beaucoup me promener dans les villes et
ce qui m'intéressait au départ dans les
vignes c'est plutôt l'architecture au
fil de ses promenades monsieur de plus
en plus aperçus qui avait alors des
graffitis qui moi personnellement
m'intéresse moins mais aussi des des
fresques à ce moment-là Nathalie
bourgeoiserie fait des recherches livres
et applications mobiles elle développe
sa passion pour le street art en
parcourant les rues des plus grandes
villes alors sur une ville comme
Bordeaux qui a taille un peu plus
humaine que Paris c'est vrai que moi
quand je vais à Bordeaux j'essaye de
voir ce qui est un artiste que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle Charles froussard
par exemple je vais aller rechercher
voir les œuvres nouvelles qu'il a pu
qu'il a pu commettre dans Bordeaux j'ai
eu la chance de pouvoir aller aux
États-Unis parce c'est aussi la patrie
du street art et notamment New York ou
Philadelphie quand elle n'est pas en
quête d'oeuvre d'art urbain Nathalie
bourgeois de Rick est à la cour d'appel
de Versailles depuis septembre 2022 elle
occupe la fonction de première
présidente de chambre auprès du premier
président Jean-François beneL je vais
avoir une double casquette en fait je
vais être à la fois magistrat comme tous
mes collègues avec des audiences et puis
je reste cette casquette de d'animateur
d'un d'un gros service puisque j'aurai
21 chambres à animer donc 21 x 3 vous
faites le calcul ça fait un certain
nombre de magistrats avec les le pôle
civil classique le pôle commercial le
pôle social et le pôle famille avec 30
ans d'expérience dans la magistrature
d'auditrice à la Cour de cassation en
passant par juge pour enfants au
tribunal d'Evry jusqu'à la
vice-présidence du tribunal d'instance
de Longjumeau Nathalie bourgeois de Ric
a atteint le plus haut grade de
magistrats or hiérarchie
avant de se quitter petit point sur la
météo de demain
[Musique]
8 météo capricieuse pour ce jeudi 22
décembre le soleil tentera quelques
sorties mais des plus épars sont annoncé
à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles des
éclaircies sont annoncés à Houdan et
Rambouillet du côté des températures
comptées 11 degrés sur la plus grande
partie du département l'après-midi c'est
la grisaille qui sera des nôtres des
plus épars sont attendus à Houdan et
Rambouillet du côté de Mantes-la-Jolie
de Versailles le temps sera très nuageux
au niveau des températures pas de grands
changements un petit degré de plus par
rapport au matin 12 degrés dans le
département sauf à Rambouillet où il
fera 11 degrés et demain nous fêterons
les Françoise à Xavier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi de
cette huître revient demain pour une
nouvelle émission très belle soirée sur
TV 78
[Musique]